[Musique]
couture coiffure soudure ou broderie la
délégation nippone venus s'inspirer au
musée écoutent attentivement les
explications sur le savoir-faire des 232
métiers exposés
de ce côté ci on a de la mosaïque avec
des oeuvres très intéressante
des derniers concours 2011 2015 2018
2019 des japonais sont passées n'étaient
des liens ici et ils ont trouvé notre
musée est magnifique
donc ils ont décidé d'en construire un
chez eux au japon dans la ville de
nagoya
selon rewmi montrer comment se compose
de musée déjà j'ai rappelé que le musée
2 milliards ou et défonce et unique et
ça c'est important de dire parce que il
n'y a qu'ici qu'on ne trouve que des
oeuvres meilleur ouvrier de france
bien que français le concours de mof
connais une résonance au japon dans les
métiers de bouche par exemple les
meilleurs ouvriers de france sont de
véritables stars
en synthèse beaucoup au travail et des
meufs qui sont quand même
qui travaille en fait qu'ils sont quand
même magnifique il y en a qui font des
oeuvres magnifiques ces responsables
japonais aimerait aller plus loin et
créer ce concours au japon un engouement
qui ravit au sein des meilleurs ouvriers
de france
je pense que les japonais qui sont venus
aujourd'hui sont très intéressés par le
travail des meilleurs ouvriers de france
en général et ils ont sûrement des
artisans avec des compétences équivalent
les notes largement et il aimerait leur
ces deux cultures se rassemblent le
futur musée japonais sera inauguré à
nagoya en 2024
l'occasion aussi de célébrer le
centenaire du premier concours meilleur
ouvrier de france
[Musique]